now that the clintons are finished and
Roy Moore is on the ropes Democrats are
spewing crocodile tears over their
decades of covering up sexual abuse
against women we'll analyze their
alleged repentance then Amelia Hamilton
Jacob berry and Candace Owens joined the
panel of deplorable 'z to discuss that
insufferable millennial card game cards
against humanity' and it's vowed to
subvert immigration law the ironically
named global atheist convention reason
to hope being cancelled because no one
wants to go and the poetic diction of
President Trump's latest tweets
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
well we got a new vintage for the
leftist here's tumblr we have a new
vintage coming out this week it is the
crocodile tears vintage we haven't seen
these in a very long time but they are
they are pouring out like the likes of
which we have not seen in a while I need
to subscribe a few more times just to
contain them every Democrat across the
spectrum is pouring out crocodile tears
now that the Clintons are no longer
useful they can say oh well yeah bill
wasn't so nice to women and yeah well
Hillary intimidated all of his victims
and smeared them in the press and ruined
their lives but yeah I was we shouldn't
have done that but hey we've changed now
because Roy Moore is on the ropes just
for context let's look at Bill Clinton
accuser and alleged rape victim Juanita
Broderick then he tries to kiss me again
and the second time he tries to kiss me
[Music]
[Music]
did you resist did you turn to stop yes
until they please don't he was such a
different person at that moment he was
just a vicious colorful person is there
any way at all that Bill Clinton could
have thought this was consensual
no not with what I told him and with how
I tried to push him away it was not
consensual gee now the Clinton campaign
and the Clinton machine tried to explain
this at the time they said I think was
James Carville said this well you
dragged a hundred-dollar bill through a
trailer park
what happens that's how he that's how he
explains the way all of these accusers
like Juanita Broderick
well the tune has changed today I wonder
what's different now wonder what's
different now in 2017 than it was when
Bill Clinton and the Clinton machine was
a force in democratic politics mmm
wonder what it could be the Atlantic ran
a headline Bill Clinton a reckoning they
wrote quote if Weinstein and Mark
Halperin and louis c.k and all the rest
can be held accountable so can our
former president and so can his party
which so many americans so desperately
need to rise again there it is there's
the whole argument we just desperately
need the democrats to rise again and
that's why we're willing to do it at
least the atlantic was honest about
their motives for a kicking bill to the
curb and admitting that they're horrible
hypocrites over this issue for twenty
years thirty years Matt Iglesias at Vox
was not so honest he said quote what he
did to Monica Lewinsky was wrong and he
should have to pay the price he should
have paid the price at the time I like
most Americans was glad to see Clinton
prevail and regarded the whole sordid
matter as primarily the fault of
congressional Republicans excessive
scandal mongering now looking back after
the election of Donald Trump the
revelations of massive sexual harassment
at Fox the news stories about Harvey
Weinstein and others in the
entertainment industry and the stories
about roy moore's pursuit of sexual
relationships with teenagers i think we
got it wrong oh do you now do you now
that's well that's convenient timing is
it well at the time i was thrilled that
they brushed all of this under the rug
but now we could use it against
republicans now we got donald trump
through some allegations against him
from random people there obviously the
allegation is Roy Moore so I think I've
changed my tune now and do I have to
protect Bill Clinton anymore no I don't
it says we're gonna run again probably
but she's useless okay good now we can
move on the Jake Tapper Jake Tapper
we should play this clip first this is
Jake Tapper just within the last few
days talking about Bill Clinton the
wanita Broderick affair in light of Roy
Moore maybe it's you know something and
maybe it's the southern accent that
reminds me of this but I think we are in
and we've seen we've seen some of this
in the press there was a story in the
Atlantic
called Bill Clinton a reckoning Chris
Hayes said something the other day and
other people have
but the accusers of Bill Clinton back in
the 90s were never given the credence
and treated with the same respect that
these women are being treated and I
think that there is something to be said
about how society has evolved since then
but in addition it's hard not to look
back at that period and think you know
what the media treated those poor
there's women poorly yeah without a
doubt you can't rewrite history but what
I am concerned about now is that I see a
lot of Republicans people like Ann
Coulter on Twitter going back and
bringing up people like Senator Kennedy
Clinton other people that did have
previous acts of sexual misconduct
almost as the way of saying well they
did it we can too well you can't rewrite
history that's what she said well you
can't rewrite history what can you say
but let's talk about more Republicans
yeah well I know Jake you brought up
Bill Clinton but look you can't rewrite
history isn't that right now good on
Tapper for bringing this up I guess but
again this timing is just so absurd that
it's really hard for me to take him
seriously he wrote a piece by the way
during the biggest Clinton scandal
Monica Lewinsky he wrote a piece for
Washington City paper titled I dated
Monica Lewinsky he went on a date with
her I guess he said quote physically she
was pleasant without being overwhelming
she's a little chubby
but she's leaps and bounds prettier than
that vacuous mugshot beamed all over the
world and I will say he does sort of
defend her in that piece but he trotted
her out for a good tabloid article in
that paper when he was just a young
reporter just like everybody else and
he's had this epiphany the Epiphany that
oh we should have been harder on Bill
Clinton just right after the Clintons
are no longer useful to them and it
would be it would benefit Democrats to
sweep them under the rug because Jake
Tapper par excellence in recent years
flax for Democrats in the New York Times
Michelle Goldberg an op-ed columnist
were at a piece called quote I believe
Juanita now she actually goes further in
this piece than her Co partisans and she
defends the Democrats at the time but
she says there were plenty of reasons to
disbelieve Paula Jones some of the
accusers etc but nevertheless we should
throw bill under the bus now because he
isn't useful to us anymore
it isn't just Bill Clinton though
Democrat anti-trump fanatic louis c.k
has gone down Anthony Weiner very
famously has gone down bizarrely Jon
Stewart was good friends even a roommate
with both of them here is Jon Stewart
talking about louis c.k his good pal
friend and colleague yes EK yes has been
accused of and has admitted down some
lewd acts involving women what was the
impact on you when you heard not only
the the accusations but his admission
done i think sarah that's right is it
well what is your hey john so i'm gonna
put you on the spot with your good
friend of decades whom you know very
well and you actually were asked this
question last year and you decided to
punt on it what what would happen when
you found out that he's a sexual pervert
was stunned yeah that's the ticket yeah
yeah yeah no that's a ticket i was
completely stunned give me a break
there is this weird thing with stuart -
because he's famously been good friends
with Louie CK for a very long time he
obviously knew about this if if everyone
else in - about this his good buddy Jon
Stewart knew about this but he also his
roommates with Anthony Weiner so when
the first when Andrew Breitbart broke
the Anthony Weiner sexting scandal or
tweeting scandal he wouldn't cover it on
the show he wouldn't cover it for days
and days and days and eventually he said
well look I'm pals with Anthony Weiner
we used to live together in Hoboken I
believe and eventually he had to cover
who's forced tubes it was so absurd he
wasn't covering the most salacious story
in politics but uh kind of a weird thing
that jon stewart is pretty tight with
both of the the most extreme sexual
deviancy stories in democratic politics
in the last decade or two a little odd
I'm not accusing him of anything but
quite a coincidence then of course
there's Hillary Clinton it all goes back
to Hillary Clinton Hillary famously said
on the campaign trail all accusers
should be believed but of course she
then was in charge of the bimbo
eruptions at the White House
she even believed those accusers she
stepped in in 2010 we've learned to
overturn President Bush's ban of a
European Islamist tariq ramadhan who is
the grandson of the founder of the
Muslim Brotherhood a Bush had banned him
from the United States she personally
stepped in to approve his visa Ramadan
has been accused of rape and sexual
assault by three women in the last 10
days she also publicly said the Juanita
Broderick was not credible and wanita by
the way says that Hillary Clinton
pressured her to stay silent so she said
bill raped her and then Hillary came up
to her pressed her hand and said we
appreciate everything you do for us and
then looked it into her eyes and said
that means everything I appreciate
everything that you do for us implying
keeping quiet about the rape now Juanita
Broderick is firmly convinced that
Hillary knew Hillary pressured or
Hillary covered it up Democrats now who
are conveniently saying yes I believe
what Nita it took 20 30 years but yeah
now I believe Juanito okay put your
money where your mouth is because if you
believe Juanita then you have then you
have to believe her whole account right
you can't just say well I believe this
but I don't believe this
she's trustworthy here but she's a liar
here you have to give evidence for that
if you believe Juanita then you believe
that Hillary Clinton knew about the rape
Hillary Clinton pressured her to stay
silent intimidated her and smeared other
victims of Bill Clinton and if you're
willing to do that and look at yourself
in the mirror and ask what changed what
made you believe Juanita because you
voted for the woman you did everything
within your power to put her into the
White House just 12 months ago
very convenient timing from Democrats
I'm not buying a bit of it for further
analysis we bring on our panel of
deplorable we have an excellent panel
today
Candace Owens Jacob Airy Amelia Hamilton
thank you for being here Amelia your
first time on the panel appreciate it
Candace you have been red-billed that's
that's your name that's your screen name
on the internet so this sort of thing
can happen people can change their minds
on plenty of things is there any chance
that this change of heart
is earnest or is it just totally cynical
nonsense it's absolutely not earnest and
in that clip that you just showed it's
just proof of that because they're
almost throwing it back on conservatives
they hate when a mirror is held up to
them but throwing it back on
conservatives well how dare
conservatives say this or say that
because they are being called out on
their hypocrisy and if it was at all
genuine then you're going live to
explain to me why they just tried very
seriously to put bill
Clinton back in the White House right
that's exactly it
it's so recent and in the saying well we
can't blame Hillary no if you believe
Juanita this you have to play Miller e's
hilly hillary is deeply at fault here
amelia in the 1990s feminists came to
bills defense led by gloria steinem they
defended him because he shared their
policy priorities is this such a bad
thing policy questions of freedom
justice security national priorities
should they really be derailed because
men are dogs i think that you can
probably find a man who isn't a dog who
shares some of your beliefs who shares
some of your policy positions and those
are probably the men to support but but
i mean particularly in these moments so
i i'm as as a man as someone who
identifies as a man i will say we're all
dogs every man is a dog we all fall
short of the glory of god and god's dog
spelled backwards by the way is that a
coincidence i don't know but in cases
like these guys it is gloria steinem
justified or republicans in alabama
justified especially in alabama where
you say all of the accusations are forty
years ago they're they seem credible to
me but regardless we're talking about
issues of freedom national politics
politicians by definition or scumbags
should we should we vote for them anyway
or should we allow the this personal
behavior from these dogs to to derail a
political agenda no we need to have some
kind of standards and you know this is
seems like a pretty pretty low bar to be
able to pass and just because they share
certain political beliefs they still
have to be decent human beings you know
and like you said politicians they tend
to be a little like you said scumbags
but you know we can't we can't just let
things of this nature especially go
because they share certain policy
beliefs we have to like i said have some
kind of standards here but should we
unilaterally disarm i mean this is the
trouble a lot of the commentary today on
clinton is if we had only held him
accountable then maybe politics wouldn't
have degraded itself such as it is you
know the founder of the treasury
department a founding father
Washington's aide to Camp Alexander
Hamilton
a famously cuckolded a man named James
Reynolds was the first sex scandal in
American history and John Adams second
president said there weren't enough
[ __ ] in Philadelphia to contain his
super abundance of secretions rather
obviously there is I see a running theme
in American politics had Democrats held
Bill Clinton to account in the 90s would
we see a politics that is not so
degraded today I think politics is
always going to be degraded and like you
said it always has been I think we just
need to hold everyone accountable always
they should have done it then we need to
keep doing it now I think things are a
lot more public now we've got social
media we've got everything else so I
think that's in a lot of ways a good
thing people know what's happening now
things are being made public and now
that they are being made public we need
to do something about it all right
that's what we have to do it is all very
public now and this whole show is public
for all of you up to this point I'm
sorry if you don't subscribe to The
Daily wire com I have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube I know we have so
much more to cover today we have the
poetic diction of Donald Trump's tweets
we have that stupid game cards against
humanity' and we make fun of atheists
but you can only do it if you go to
daily wire.com right now you haven't
even heard from Jakob era yet but
probably that's incentive to just log
off right now if you go to Facebook and
rather if you go to daily wire.com what
do you get you get me you get the
Android clave and sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show yada yada yada yada yada
but look at this folks
the leftist tears tumblr with all of the
crocodile tears pouring out from all
corners today you better get it you're
gonna have to get the Atlantic vintage
the New York Times vintage the Jake
Tapper vintage on and on and on so go
over there write down by the way
mailbags tomorrow if you subscribe today
you can submit a question I will change
your life for the better
ASAP so go there daily wire.com we'll be
right back
okay we have a lot of news to cover the
card game insufferable millennial card
game cards against humanity' is running
a holiday promotion to buy a lot of
vacant land along the us-mexico border
and prevent Trump's wall this game is
the worst it is for those of you who
haven't played it it's like a
pretentious version of apples to apples
or mad libs so that a skittish liberals
can can say some naughty words and
giggle it after one or two plays all of
the fun of it is gone you know they'll
have a one card that says the our class
trip was ruined by blank and then it'll
just have a bunch of cards that's have
different bodily fluids or racial
epithets on it or something so it's
funny for a little bit and they bill it
as a party game for horrible people in
reality though it's just a game for
liberals so that they can say some
naughty things because political
correctness is so awful then they all
giggle at how terrible it is and and
they know well we're not the real
horrible people we're not the horrible
people who you know ride tractors and
vote for Republicans and things like
that we're just we're we just sip
Chardonnay in New York and and giggle at
all of these mean things so Jacob is
cards against humanity' which bills
itself as unpeaceful political
correctness now I've never played it you
know I as far as my board games I have
higher standards but or excuse me my
card games but I'm I think this is just
them doing some virtually virtue
signaling I know some of their cards
have gotten them in trouble in the past
and you know people still buy it they
still play it but I think this is just
them saying hey yeah our card game it
may be politically incorrect but look at
us you know they're doing the they're
doing the grandstanding on on the border
as they like as they like to say that's
like Bill Clinton right yeah sure I
abused women and positions below me but
you know abortion right I'm good on
abortion Candace the millennial
generation is known is known by its
overwhelming performance of apathy this
is just something I've noticed all the
music is very apathetic ever
it's tattoos everywhere it's an
expression of philosophic nihilism you
know everything is whatever man and
we're all gonna die someday yet these
guys are so triggered by Donald Trump to
look at things with the glass half-full
is this evidence that at least this
culture of nihilism is crumbling I can't
look at this with the glass half-full
what this is is dramatic irony it tells
you why people can't take millennial
seriously I mean they put together this
game cards of humanity which you
mentioned is supposed to be this super
non-political we get to say what we want
but they can't bear the thoughts of not
allowing people that don't belong into
this country to run in here freely and
drive up everybody's taxes I mean this
is this is why people can't stand
liberals everything they do is
hypocritical and it's ironic in all of
the bad ways that you can talk about
irony and it's ironic because it's
within confines right they say oh yeah
we could say all these you know bad
things but only within this certain
social convention that we've all agree
is perfectly fine and we all have to
look at each other and you okay you're
not saying I'm not serious okay good
Emelia on that point in the old days
card games used to be complicated and
creative games used to require
creativity cards against humanity' is a
very simple card game and it completely
precludes creativity you can't be
creative at all what does the decay of
games say about our culture well decay
of culture you know I think it really
just again goes back to that lowest
common denominator it's like let's all
get together and say some horrible
things nope there's no need to have any
creativity there's no need to think
about it you know it supplies you with
the horrible things to say you don't
even need to think of those on your own
you know at least like you're saying
with Mad Libs you had to think of
something so you know people aren't
getting together and doing something
creative having some fun they're just
saying some words that were already
supplied to them and they're all and
they're so absurd I mean sometimes it's
absurd things can be funny but it gets
old the kids old and tedious pretty
quickly
would think though that a culture that
is decadent a culture that has fallen
into disrepair and nihilism you would
think that it would make its recreation
complicated and because that's what its
own that's what it's focused on but
instead this is just the laziest game
ever is it is it evidence of a sloth in
in the millennial generation or am I
reading too much into this stupid game
no I think absolutely you know this is
the the post mates kind of of games
where everything is just being handed to
you and you just just sit there and
throw your cards out and there's nothing
else required nothing and no creativity
no strategy just this is mine here we go
yeah marching off to the grave
the third speaking of that speaking of
all of those philosophic ideas the third
annual global atheist convention
ironically called recent to oath has
been canceled because nobody wanted to
go Emelia after a decade of totally
undeserved plaudits given to Richard
Dawkins Daniel Dennett Sam Harris
Christopher Hitchens who's writing I
enjoy but whose thoughts aren't that
smart has his atheism piqued are we
headed right now for a religious
reawakening you know people really are
searching for some kind of meaning and
people used to get it from things like
religion and you know now we're finding
you know people are going to the
theology of Harry Potter talks you know
where they find out you know following
that as sort of some kind of a religious
experience and people are really
searching for that kind of meaning for
that kind of guidance in their lives and
they they aren't finding it from the
traditional places and I think maybe
we're gonna see people turning back to
that yeah I think they should look to
the traditional places because they're
not funny in Harry Potter it is so sad
that our generation that the myth is
Harry Potter that's what we're grounding
our mythical thinking it's really really
pathetic I think Harold Bloom said it
would be better for the literary critic
Harold Bloom said that it would be
better for children to watch television
than to read Harry Potter because all of
it whenever as no one ever just takes a
walk they all it's all these awful
cliches like oh I'm going to stretch my
legs they always just stretch their legs
every take
walk Candace there is significant
evidence that the post Millennials this
is the cause for hope I'm gonna make you
hopeful before the end of this show so
help me God
there's significant evidence that the
post Millennials Gen Z are far more
religious and church-going than we
Millennials because as amelia just said
they're looking for meaning what what is
causing this return to religion
obviously they're looking for meaning
but what what is the the immediate cause
in our time of that I don't really know
that's a really good question maybe when
you get to a point when you have so much
invested in the books written by JK
Rowling and then you read her Twitter
feed you realize that you realize that
you need God in your life and you are
going down that's a profound thought
actually because the this generation has
made gods out of people who do not
deserve to be gods they made gods as
celebrities they've made profits out of
JK Rowling and then you look at their
behavior you look at their Twitter feed
you look at everything and you realize
that everybody falls short of the glory
of God and certainly Hollywood is a you
know we all fall short by those guys
well like a lot shorter and so that
might be it there's been a betrayal by
our gods and even the philosophic gods
that we've made for ourselves
environmentalism all of the ideologies
that have come to replace Marxism and
therefore traditional religion they've
failed us we don't I don't know if it
would be too far to say you know
Nietzsche thought that god is dead but
really we've learned that all the other
things are dead too and we have to go
back to that first one JK the irony of
this convention title is that atheism of
course means there is no hope we just
we're born we die we turn to worm food
you know good play yet in every
civilization at all times throughout
history man has demonstrated a longing
for God is this just a cosmic joke on
mankind or is that longing evidence that
God exists I think that the longing is
evidence that God exists as as far as
you know reasons to hope I think it's
more the very title of the conference
tells
that it's not just atheism that has
piqued its nihilism that has peaked
because you know it's funny when Jerry
Seinfeld is doing it right you know a
show about nothing but no one wants to
think that their life means nothing they
don't expect it to be you know like
William Shakespeare or dr. King jr. but
they want their life to have some sort
of mean and it's funny Seinfeld is funny
because it's absurd we're laughing at
these people with their meaningless
meaningless lives and that's why I think
that it's kind it was kind of ironic
that they called it a reason to hope
because if atheism is true there is no
reason to hope you know it's always
going to be the the greater species is
always going to conquer the lesser
species because that's just how
Darwinian ISM works but I think that
that yes that longing is a sign that God
exists out there and this convention is
a sign that God exists I've always fact
that got canceled is a sign that God
exists in my experience of God he's a
pretty whimsical fella
and so the atheists name this convention
absurdly a reason for hope and then in
itself it's a reason to despair and then
it gets cancelled and we get a reason to
hope he God can turn everything even the
death of his own son for for good even
the fall of mankind for good a Felix
culpa okay speaking of reasons to hope
we have to get to trumps torrent of
grade-a 100% pure Colombian I was forced
to watch CNN which I have not done in
months and again realized how bad and
fake it is loser do you think the three
UCLA basketball players will say Thank
You president Trump they were headed for
ten years in jail and then another great
one the failing New York Times hates the
fact that I have developed a great
relationship with world leaders like
jumping president of China by the way
capitalization is getting up a little
wonky in some of these they should
realize that these relationships are a
good thing not a bad thing to us the
u.s. is being respected again watch
trade it is actually hard to believe how
naive
or dumb the failing New York Times's
when it comes to foreign policy weak and
ineffective so what it is so it is so
poetic Jacob to play devil's advocate if
this were Democrat doing this we would
be losing our ma we going insane with
anger is it okay to applaud Trump's
tweets as I just did
just because he's a Republican well not
just because he's a Republican but I
absolutely and even me I've said many
times on the show I am a trump skeptic
I'm not I'm not a never Trump ER and I'm
not on the Trump train but I'm a skeptic
but I actually admire this about Trump
Republicans have forever been saying hey
let's say we need a president who will
stick it right to the media and so I'm
actually enjoying this greatly I think
it's a thrill ride and maybe you know if
Brock if President Obama had done this
you know I might have been a little
disturbed by it but hey I you know call
me a hypocrite if you want but I am
enjoying it completely because President
Trump just has this way of doing it
where you just have to laugh you just go
oh my gosh you know he just took on the
New York Times and CNN and it was
amazing if Obama had done it it would be
totally bizarre and terrifying and but
it's because of how they've built their
careers both of them both Obama and
Trump built their careers such that they
exposed enough of themselves that
aspects of them that might scare people
or no longer scary so Barack Obama did
this in his book Dreams from My Father
he talked about how his father was a
Muslim bigamist basically the Atheist I
suppose and he was raised in these
Muslim schools in Indonesia and he did a
bunch of coke and he was around radical
leftists and he was friends with leftist
terrorists and the thing about that book
I will say by the end of it you're not
afraid of him he makes it not scary same
with Trump if you just flew in from Mars
right now you would say the earth is on
the brink of collapse but if you've
followed Trump for 40 years and you've
followed his influences as a matter of
persuasion and rhetoric and media you
say no I see where this is going
from I see what he's doing here now to
your point on the culture warrior Emilia
many of the so-called conservatives who
have spent decades calling for culture
Warriors are now demure because Trump is
waging those battles is the Donald the
culture warrior that we have been
waiting for well I guess it depends on
who we is we on the right we broadly as
conservatives before the trumpian ISM
came in the conservative movement of
Bill Buckley and Bill Kristol and Irving
Kristol and but you know I don't think
that he's necessarily helpful I think
that the the message frequently gets
drowned in the messenger in the delivery
so so while I think the culture war is
important I don't think it's necessarily
being waged in the most hopeful way that
it could be but I wonder with that
because people say oh if he'd only said
it more politely than then it would work
but I I don't I don't really see that
george w bush was a very polite man he
didn't do a terribly bang-up job in the
culture war and with donald trump he
misspells a word he capitalizes a word
wrong he chooses strange language and
then it's all we can talk about his
tweets are all anyone has talked about
for two years is it is it not possibly
the case that four people and I don't
mean to call out these guys I like them
personally but Bill Kristol and Jonah
Goldberg and the never Trump crowd out
of NR and weekly standard is it possible
just that they wanted this culture
warrior they wanted to fight the culture
and they had a vision of it and they
didn't expect it to look like this and
so now that we get no one expected it to
look like this now that we have it that
we don't recognize it you know I really
I mean that's that's certainly possible
I don't know I still think that it's
just not quite quite the warrior that we
wanted you guys are depressing me you're
very you have you got to make me feel
better at some point but can this first
make me feel worse
The Washington Post ran a story today
quote Trump's Asia trip was hardly the
success he says it was that was in the
news section
was not an op-ed that was not an
editorial they filed that under news
they passed that off under news of
course they offered no evidence it was
absolute tripe the so called foreign
policy analysis if the Washington Post
and CNN and the New York Times are going
to behave like children without any
journalistic standards having to recant
stories having to fire a reporting staff
then it shouldn't we treat them like the
children that they are shouldn't
President Trump to treat them like the
children that they are I think
altogether we need to stop talking about
the Washington Post that is Jeff Bezos
personal diary okay his feelings his
thoughts go into burning feelings and
thoughts which aren't based in facts are
written for the world everybody
understands the Washington Post is
literally just his play toy at this
point to go back to your earlier point I
absolutely love what Trump is doing I
think he is the cultural word that
people were looking for people meaning
us people that hold jobs and what we
watch our TV screens we are so tired of
hearing politicians we are so tired of
somebody making something that's
horrible sound agree wrapping it into a
bow and presenting to us the same BS
that we get all the time we want
somebody who talks like us when I look
at the TV and I'm watching CNN and
they're lying to me I'm going loser you
know is able to do so effectively he
talks like he's talking to the people
for the people he's not dressing
anything up in a tuxedo and I just I
want to make your day better Michael by
letting you know that I think he is the
cultural and I love your point of
talking about people he's a guy who
doesn't speak in this mealy-mouthed
particular language of politics he
speaks like regular people speak don't
get me wrong I am all for elites
I'm all for elitism and elites but they
have to actually be elites they have to
be Royals they have to be aristocrats
they have to be seriously educated and
wise and sophisticated and well behaved
and these people who have been
pretending to be elites for decades and
in American politics simply are not
there is absolutely no reason for me to
respect journalists CNN or the New York
Times or Jeff P SSE's personal letter to
the world or there's no reason they're
not actually elites they don't know
anything they don't possess wisdom so it
give me an elite and I'll consider
respecting them but until then give me a
give me a straight talker absolutely
right okay
panel excellent to have you here you
took me on a journey of emotions I was
so depressed I was so happy there at the
end Amelia thank you for being here
first time Candis Owens and Jacob berry
thanks for coming back we will talk to
you all again soon that's our show
that's the whole thing folks I got to
get out of here to read the thousand
mailbag questions that are waiting if
you haven't subscribed already
well I subscribing already if you're
watching this now and if you're
listening over to Daily wire and
subscribe so you can send in a mailbag
question that'll be tomorrow we have a
great interview by the way with Eric
Metaxas coming tomorrow over Martin
Luther he refutes some of my objections
to the corpulent German heretic and we
have a good conversation about his new
book Martin Luther and and then I'll
answer all of your questions so I am
Michael Knowles as the Michael knows
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera and our
Associate Producer is Bailey Lynn the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017